hello everyone hey please close the door
yeah thank you hello everyone having a
good time so far yes excellent
conference this is the session about C++
unit testing the good the bad and the
ugly coming to this session and come
from a background of several different
object-oriented and dynamic languages
and it always amazes me that there are
differences between C++ and those
languages and as far as unit testing
tools and unit testing in general and
that's what I'm going to talk about
today and the good news is that C++ in
some aspect is much better than the
others by the way but before that an
introduction my name is draw helper I'm
a consultant and Software Architect been
working in the software industry for
more than a decade and somewhere along
the line about ten years ago I've
stumbled or found a job with an agile
company agile startup and learned all
about agile and unit testing and TDD and
really liked it and ever since I've been
speaking about those topics and mental
and developers and and whatever just
spread in the world how to write better
code because we still have a lot to
cover as developers as software
developers in the software industry in
order to improve the way we do in stuff
I'm also a Pluralsight author
I have several courses on global site of
which about C++ unit testing one about
unit testing fundamentals would catch
any testing thermo-calc talked about
today and that one about mocking with
Google Mach and feel free to check them
out I have a blog at helper code comm
where I speak about I write about
anything I find interesting usually
software related and I have a twitter
handle ad helper when you can reach me
and I'll get notified immediately on my
watch so if you want to ask questions or
comments just feel free
and we are going to talk about C++ unit
testing but before that let's talk about
C++ because C++ is an amazing language
it enabled us to do so many cool things
first of all it is a multi pattern kind
of language we can write code procedural
functional object-oriented
meta programming you name it it's also a
very performant and highly treatable
kind of language we can affect our
marriage memory we use how fast or slow
a program will run and we have so much
control we don't have in any other
language at least once I saw and it is
truly a multi-platform language right
unlike other languages who claim to be
multi-platform starting with the j c++
is really multi-platform it can run on
any computer any platform any machine
any chip you can think about and I've
been in those projects and it's amazing
to write your code once compile it
anywhere and then you get the same
results and it plays nice with other
languages because usually we don't live
in a void we want our C++ code base to
be able accessible from other languages
such as Python or Java or C shop vb.net
if you do that oh you want to call those
libraries from our library in a harness
some library someone else's vote and
it's highly extensible we can create our
own syntax in C+ as essentially we can
do amazing stuff we can define new types
and we can override operators and we can
play with macros and do things that
other languages can only dream about
it's also a good language for a
low-level programming who here loves
low-level programming okay not as many
as I expected but yeah good for you we
can call the GPU or the CPU or inspects
processes running in the operating
system and that's because all of those
were written using C and C++ the
operating system and other compilers for
the languages and even languages that
now have a managed compiler such a
c-sharp that managed compiler was
tennessee plus plus and the run time the
running on with this night nifty garbage
collection they have was also written in
c++ which means that as c++ developer i
can somehow even know the way it was
implemented I can really understand
those low-level internals because I've
written similar code now all of you are
C++ developer who is a C++ developer
resident okay most of the room right
yeah okay yeah we only write C++ in one
platform windows for example okay and
the rest was a do it for any other
platform under the Sun nice and well I
gave the I gave this talk in NDC Oslo
there we had a lot of windows developers
but different conference so C++ is a
powerful language but with that great
power come great responsibility because
you really can mess things up with C++
right you can cause amazing colossal
problem with C++ given to the right or
wrong developer C++ can cause crashes
and faults and memory allocation issues
you just have to name it so we need
something in order to improve and
obviously education is one of them we
need to really understand what all
software does and how it does it and
know how we allocate or the allocate
things and again how is the memory the
file system or whatever is most relevant
to your line of work but I found there
is one tool and I'm highly biased that
helps me and that is writing automated
test as well specifically unit testing
but not only unit testing because once I
start using unit testing by the way
before I start will write unit tests so
it's it was first program excellent this
is most of the whom this usually doesn't
happen usually I get the feel free
people shall is raising their hands so
if you do write unit tests then you're
fine because writing unit tests means I
can avoid those stupid bugs when I was a
young developer just starting my
I didn't know any better I used to hack
as quickly as I can
punch the keyboard finishing that
specific task committed for it over
defense to the next developer in line or
a tester he will try to run that's my
software and it will immediately crash
with the unittest that shouldn't happen
that doesn't happen because all of those
stupid bags of dangling pointers or
accidentally going overboard with your
days need to be caught in this stage all
those stupid bugs disappear once you
start to write test for the code and you
get an early feedback because the thing
I hate the most on writing software is
that two weeks after finish writing
something I'll get a bug report and if I
get a bug report after two weeks I have
a problem because I'm already working on
something else and I forgot what I did
two weeks ago and usually the bug report
well depends on the tester you're
working with but some of them are not
very detailed some of them I used I got
a basketball saying software just
crashed good luck and then you try to
reproduce that bad report obviously
doesn't happen on your machine and then
you say it works on my machine and you
mark the bug as cannot be reproduce and
the testers get very annoyed with that
and reopen the bug and you started a
small fight about that they take a few
days maybe a few weeks until you
actually get to fix that bug I want to
find my problems as quickly as I can
once I write them I want them to be
found don't want to wait till a tester
or a customer find them for me and then
the selling point for unit testing most
of the time people bring me in to
explain and teach about unit tests when
they find out they have a lot of the
duration bugs they keep on breaking
stuff because this is a painful thing to
do you'll fit something and you break
something and you fix that and you break
the first thing again and once you have
a lot of unit tests you have a safety
net that protects you from regression
and you can write sustainable and
manageable code because something funny
happens when you start to write
automated test your code your design
changes you start to write
very loosely coupled design you start to
divide your dependencies from your coal
business and your code changes to the
better I I don't buy this old design for
testability thing I designed for
readability and maintainability I get to
test it because of that but that's it my
code becomes better half dependency
injection and I have different classes
with single responsibility for each and
it brings me for a battle of jakku
vented design intuitively without
thinking about it
and finally unit ourselves kind of
documentation list for me because I got
code as fast as I read English and that
is a good thing that means that when I
get to the same project I worked on a
month ago or even before lunch all I
need to do is read the test random debug
them and understand how the code works
and unlike the text document that you
might have written your design document
it doesn't get stilled
because the test progress with your code
keep on changing and updated as your
code updates so unit test is a good
thing to have and it's a very simple
thing that unit tests
unfortunately not only we have a lot of
definition of what a unit test is and
you can argue about it till it turned
blue in the face I found that there is
no clear definition of what is a unit as
out there you know Google it you find
several definitions some of them written
by speakers that came here today and so
I have my own definition you know if you
can't beat them join them and my
definition of unit test is very simple
it's a method a unit test is essentially
a method all of us know how to write
those there are different tools but it
is essentially a method and don't let
anyone lie to you there are no such
thing as a unit testing framework those
are method running frameworks and that's
it they have nothing to do really with
unit tests don't really check that you
are writing a unit test the just one
code but the thing that makes it a unit
test is that unlike the code rat in
production it tests a very specific
functionality this is the thing of fun
developers find the hardest thing to
think about the
because when we like production code we
usually need to tackle all of the
possible option out there an interest is
called the complete opposite now that a
single unit tests attest something very
specific and it's out wrap your head
around if you've been writing unit tests
for some time and usually in the
beginning they fail because they are too
complex and they have a lot of logic in
them and then you reduce that and you
get to that specific functionality also
unit tests have a very clear pass or
fail criteria which seems trivial but
have been in organizations in which they
will run tests automatically and then
someone will get in the book in the
morning some very poor developer or
tester and check the database or the
server or the logs to decide whether or
not the test has passed and I don't want
that I want those tests to run
automatically and just notify me when
they fail and finally unit tests unlike
integration or accepting tests that I
can write using a unit testing framework
run in isolation you don't get to call
anything outside your code you don't
call access servers and you don't call
any database and probably not a lot of
third-party libraries but that's up to
how you hold your code and what you use
and the reason we're doing that is
because we want those tests to run on
any machine including the build server
easily I wanted us not to affect one
another I don't want the ordering of the
way they run the test the effect of the
test walk they should walk in any order
in any way I should be able to run the
same tests a thousand times get us
exactly the same result because if it
fails I want to run it at least one more
time to see what happens
now all if this done by this simple guy
a method of unit test anyone recognized
that one this is Google tests who will
uses Google tests this is the most
popular C++ unit testing framework out
there I'm not sure for the good reason
is that it was the first or at least the
first maintained one well one of the
first and but all of them look roughly
the same and if you go to other
languages you can probably recognize the
sense
rupture and the structure is combined
form this in simplest assets amico right
or the veterans it was just no
developers know that if I write it with
uppercase its macro and that mecco
essentially does a few things for me it
creates a new class in the background
and you method in that class and write
somewhere that this is a test and it
should be then when I learned my tests
and in Google test I will create an
executable that run all the tests with
or without any parameters basically so
this is the mecca that makes everything
happen I need I have the name of the
class in the background we usually call
those tests pictures this is a like a
grouping of several tests that are
something related to one another either
the test the same component the same
part of the system or the same
functionality but essentially it's a
class in object-oriented and this is my
actual test now in Google test it must
be something that can be compiled as a
method name because it is the meta name
and I try to use uppercase lowercase and
underscore to make it barely human
readable so I will understand why that
has failed and what he does here in the
middle is the important part this is
where I do stuff I usually do three
things in an in every test first of
which is a range I'll arrange the system
I'll do something in the system to get
to the point in which I came and
whatever I'm trying to test here I only
need to create a new object and the
second part is the act part this is the
play button that's well I'll run the
experiment the test I want to check and
the final one is an assert usually
called the self but it depends on the
any testing framework and that assert
will check something for me in this case
check that I'll get false back from this
method and that's it this is a very
simplistic view of a unit test but even
more complex logic can be fit inside
those walls now in C++ and in any other
language to tell you the truth a unit
testing framework so called unit testing
framework will give me at least we think
first of which I can declare test and
test picture which are the containers of
this test and might have some behavior I
need alcohol have a bunch of assertions
the number of assertions depending on
the unit testing framework and its
capabilities enable me to check for
certain conditions they must specify the
assert the better because I'll get a
better error message when it fails and
test runners in C passes in most unit s
in thermo Canal I'll actually create an
executable so I'll get to run that but
sometimes some unit isn't a mocha
bundled with specific program to run
them and especially in Windows and
sometimes I get integrated runner if you
walk in Windows you can run some of
those from Visual Studio IO you can run
for me cleats in Linux after doing some
trickling because most of the time I
want to have them form within my
development environment now in C++ unit
testing there are good good news and bad
news the good news is that you have a
lot of choices there are a lot of unit
testing framework in C++ I never seen so
many in net in one language and more
than that there are a lot of styles
because usually a unit testing framework
any language you choose looks about the
same the same way it was invented with
j-unit back I don't know 2002 or 3 1997
thank you yeah on a plane to a
conference they invented that one day oh
that one comes back and Eric gamma and
they wrote a unit with ideas that was
right for 1997 a time that at least I
wasn't in the software industry and no
one has changed that unless you go to
C++ where people thought about metal
ideas of testing your code and I'll show
you those the bad thing is that you
don't always get to the code your
documentation
most of those are the open source
projects people hacking away in the
middle of the night and so they don't
really have a lot of time to either
commentation and well most of time you
don't need it but when you
you need it you wish you had it when you
need to do something which is not
trivial
and amazingly enough well I'll talk
about it but the one with the least
amount of documentation is the one that
is maintained by the actual company and
not all unit testing for Moka maintains
just like any other open-source project
some of them are maintained I've just
updated my demos because some of those
frame oak was recent the the one was
updated yesterday people keep on working
on them all the time but some of them
haven't been for years and the ugly one
is deployment because in C++ we don't
have yet well we have some tries to have
a better package management
Coenen or VC package for Microsoft but
it is could be a pain to deploy dot unit
testing framework and some of those
options you need to compile your unit
testing framework itself and you need to
compile it the same way you compile your
test and your code you know if it's the
bug or the lists multi-threaded
single-sided compartment the same
platform and so on which can be very
frustrating especially when you get it
wrong and then then you get a bunch of
very funny link messages which is a
terrible thing to solve just because you
compiled something not exactly the same
way happened to me a day before cause
you don't want that and in case of
Windows if you compile with the
different Visual Studio then it's no
goal you'll have a bunch of linking
problems and you won't get away with
that and it can become painful now the
good news about that is that many unit
testing framework authors understood
that and they have better solutions so
in we have quite a lot of unit testing
framework and I'm sure I'm missing some
I try to get as complete list as I could
and I'll try to show at least a few of
those the first of which is obviously
Google tests in my experience every
single client I got to at least
considered working with Google tests
because
it's widely used it's out of that the
go-to guy for unit testing in C++ they
dominated the market for almost forever
and it's not a bad yeah Google test and
then I have Microsoft try its native
unit testing if you go into Visual
Studio and create a new native C++ unit
as in project you got something called
I'll call its native MS test I'm not
sure what its name is and it goes in a
completely different direction different
API and different way to walk then all
the others and then this is my favorite
catch because catch was written and by
the way by phil nash works for JetBrains
right now and it has a lot of very
interesting ideas i think it's one of
the first unit testing framework that
actually looked at j unit and said no i
don't want to do that I want to do
something completely different and I
think I got it right for my experience
if someone starts with catch you'll miss
a lot of the pitfalls that people fall
in using Google test not because it's a
bad thermic it just drives you in the
right direction and the CPP unit it was
created in 2000 2000 by Michael feathers
because he wrote a book called walking
effectively with legacy code and you
need a unit testing framework for C++ so
you got a unit testing framework for C++
and there's boost test anyone ever use
boost test okay was it fun it's very
well both a lot of things you need to
write there
you could like it it's up to you you
actually like this micro management kind
of style that's okay
not judging anyone and there's doc tests
doctors is interesting it is one of the
first unit testing framework that looked
at catch and says I want that exactly
but a bit different it has similar
syntax but you get to write your test
inside your production code and actually
filner saw that and an enabled catch to
do the same so you get back and forth
with ideas there
and the idea is that you right inside
your production code you let your tests
and Delhomme compilation depending on
whatever preprocessor the definition use
the test could disappear completely when
you want to give the code to your
customer or it can run if you want to
run your test right now and it enable
you to test things that you can test
from outside your library or executable
and there's less this is another layer I
call them catch derivative it took the
same ideas catches change them a bit
it's more manual kind of sign your test
in line way I'll show you that
and there's actually plus plus that one
actually looked at the project in dotnet
called X unit and said I want that API
and created a similar API in C++ and
there's metal metal is completely
different from all the others it has a
syntax you might like and I found it to
be very effective when you want to scare
off Java developers let's see the let's
eat all those shall we now this project
is on github everything under the helper
you can find that and I'll give you the
link at the end of the session this is
Google test as I showed you I'm testing
a bowling score in game there's a
bowling cutter anyone ever saw the
bowling game cutter you can you might
get that yeah in the job interview and
the ideas you get a bunch of results of
playing both the bowling game and you
check the score and here in Google test
I'll create a new game all several
gutter ball which means I have no score
and it should be zero okay now this feel
fine thing here is actually resharper
for c++ that enable me to run the test
formula in the code but i could have
also run it from command line or even
these days even using visual studio i
might be able this is actually the
sharper but i might be able to see the
test here as well once it stops reading
them it will bubble bank find a bunch of
tests and i'm sure we can create the
same effect in linux using your idea of
choice now when run in this state
have all seven eyeballs and check the
score now the most important thing about
any unit testing framework is the old
message and we'll get when it fails
because as far as I'm concerned I'm only
writing those tests to fail if I had a
way to know which test will fail and
which will not I will delete all the
tests that will never fail but there's
no way to predict the future is not yet
because those tests are written to catch
me when I write a bug and that's it and
the rest of it is wasting CPU and my
time so at least the least I can do is
if the test fails I want the best error
message I can think of now let's make it
fail if I'll do that it's bound to fail
on it using resharper this time and hope
for the best
yes you know it's running and it failed
and I get a nice level message and it
doesn't matter which unit testing
framework you you choose run this
experiment and see what happens see
whether or not you can understand the
problem and here it's very easy to
understand because Google test does an
excellent job itself tells me what I
expected to get tells me what I checked
the actual method and it tells me the
actual results this is excellent
and Google test has a lot of those
results if I look at a certain score
I'll get a very long list it has a third
F their application actually crashed
which I didn't find any other unit
testing firm couldn't do that or exit
and there's the usual suspect false Ness
with that here we go
and yeah and greater and equal and
result Neal and did in for an exception
all use your own predicate these days
with lambdas we can define what we want
the test to check and so on and so on
and there's quite a lot of those and
screens related and so on so this is
actually pretty cool although I have
another session about what I hate about
unit testing framework I hate using the
right result
I found developers usually in the
beginning users are true for everything
because that's way we think and
should be that way and that's the first
thing I actually like about catch
because if we go down here or up there
he will go and look at the same test
with catch here we go this is exactly
the same cat s would catch it looks
related about the same right but there's
one big difference and this is it in
catch we don't have a lot of asserts we
have about five of those and we usually
use only one and this is it require and
write the actual code right wide to
expect the test to do and that's it and
I like to write in code and
unfortunately no other language enable
me to do that that nice you know in
dotnet and Java you can have the same
effect because not only does I write it
in code but when I do get an error
message you know using zippers are
strictly and it's easier in many
languages to do the same thing I
actually did that for one client and
when I run the same test again with my
catch test you see the error message you
will choir games code to be equal zero
and zero ten and zero is not then you
get a very good hello message because
catch knows most of the thing you try to
write there if I would have tried to
compare strings it will understand that
or something inside the collection and
so on and this is a powerful
capabilities because I don't need to
think about what I'm testing just write
it in code which I find easier so that's
the first thing I really like about
catch oh it's a we have other options
here as well first of which as I said a
bit different is Microsoft option they
so what everybody else did and decide to
go a different route and that ought very
similar to what you'll see in Java
and.net you define a test class and give
it a name and inside you have fields and
public test methods which is the actual
test you have this Arabic all kind of
you exeunt LastPass will do the same
thing for you now I found this library
to be lacking it doesn't have enough
asserts for my benefits and it doesn't
almost know the commutation whatsoever
but if your windows only shop it will
run out of the box and unlike the other
guys it doesn't create an executable you
can only run it using visual studio from
here or visual studio panel from the
command line
unlike the other languages where you
just execute the code which can be
problematic if you're using other built
systems not visual studio ones and I
also found this I'll key I don't really
like it that much but that's my
preference and I promise at least one
more or less it is less it's very
similar to catch but you have to create
a specification array and then inside
that you write all the tests here let's
test case and then it we need to
explicitly run those specifications now
this was handled differently by
different unit testing framework for
example in Google test I just need to
find what the main probably he'll does
the main because it's an executable you
need to write this magic those two in
order to run the tests and in catch he
said well no need to rewrite that code
anytime I'll add a new unit testing
framework so there's a define that do
that for me many languages do that as
well another thing about catcher as
always do like it is that all you need
to do in order to use that is include a
header file which will also work for
list and doc test many others and you
don't need to compile anything and you
can somehow get to Google test to do the
same thing you can compile it to a
single C++ file and add it to your
project but it's a pain and just
including a file easier although your
compilation times might be longer due to
that because you compile in it as well
and that's all I need to use catch
include the header file and defined is
define beforehand and I am ready to
write s so deployment is easier so this
was a quick overview of all those the
others are derivative it
of how Google test does things how
Microsoft does things or how catch does
things with slight differences between
them API was usually the another tool I
usually need is a mocking thermic mo
confirm walk were here was in my session
yesterday okay not enough so I need to
explain a mocking framework essentially
is when I need to isolate dependencies I
have a database or server I don't want
to call those in my unit test so what I
do I take the class that caused the
database inherited and override all the
methods and I end up with a class that
does absolutely nothing and this is
essentially a mocking framework that's
all it does and you get a fake object
that you can shove into your code
somehow and replace the dependency you
don't want to run and you get to tell
that mocking framework exactly what you
want I don't like calling that a mocking
framework because it's very misleading
and cause you not use it perhaps a lot
of developers thinks that mocks is very
complex you can actually write your own
just inherit the class override all the
methods but I don't want to because
someone will do it for me
and I want to change the behavior in
every test and so I use a mocking
framework that will enable me to create
those fake objects and set behavior
because in one test I want to for an
exception because the server is not
there there so the server the effect
server and another day I want to return
some message and that way I get to
isolate the code and care about the code
and testing from the outside environment
and the last thing a mocking framework
will enable me to do is to check whether
or not something was called now also a
good bad and ugly kind of situation the
good is that they are mocking framework
for C++ they want to begin with there
are mocking framework right now and we
have quite a few now we didn't have a
lot in the beginning all we are this
Google mock the bad thing is yeah
everybody uses Google mock it's not a
bad mocking thermic in the beginning it
was only the only one now today this
year a couple of years last year's we
have a few more and you need to be
boiled because the some of the oils are
not maintained anymore and the ugly one
is that in most of them I'd still need
to write quite a lot of code which I
don't like because god I write is a KO
is code I need to maintain whenever my
depends he has a new method the holes
changes signature I need to change my
marks accordingly and most of them were
written a while ago especially Google
Mach and they don't really look like
triple-a it's not a range actor search
and they have a bunch of ideas that I
don't really like for example you need
to define all of the calls that will
happen in your system and then you write
your tests and you write your Mach tell
them I expect me today and let it be to
be called and someone changes the
production code add another method
another method call you don't care about
that in your test but Google Mach will
be very angry with you about that and it
will give you'll get warning or else
depending on how you initialize it and I
don't care about that specific call
someone had a call to my code didn't
change the flow I'm actually testing my
test should continue to execute the same
way and unfortunately that's not the way
we thought things should happen in way
way back and these days modern mocking
framework doesn't do that anymore
but in C++ some of them still do and
what do we have in C++ we have Google
mock as I said come bundled with Google
tests very good integration with one
another so usually when using Google
tests people tend to use Google mock as
well there's Tom plays written by beyond
was I think speaking in the next room
and not supposed to the other one and
it's very similar to Google mock but a
lot of modernizing done there it's a
single header deployment as well and
there are some ideas I think are good in
hindsight some of them I think he made a
mistake I think he did the right choice
there and it's very interesting to use
there's hippo mock which still around
but I haven't seen it been updated for
some time and there's one innovative one
called fake it fake it although doesn't
mock everything just like Google mock it
will only mock your virtual functions
and you can't have multiple inheritance
but you don't need to write classes it
will automatically in the background do
some magic to create your mocks class
and there's isolator plus plus
disclaimer used to work for that company
which does something completely
different it uses a runtime
instrumentation to change your actual
code during runtime to do absolutely
nothing for you cost money quite a bit
but you might want to use that because
you don't want to refactor your code and
you have a lot of legacy code it might
be a good option it used to be a Windows
only kind of solution but they have
Linux for the last year or so and you
might want to check it I didn't get a
lot of experience with it I don't get
any money out of it so don't worry about
that and essentially it takes all the
pain away when it works and you should
check if it works for your project it
won't work on all platforms and it does
a lot of magic in the background
dependent on your operating system of
choice let's see those quickly run on so
going up here let's start with Google
Mach always a good place to start I show
the similar I showed the same one
yesterday actually this is Google test
and here I have effect data access now
in Google Mach you have to write your
fake objects you have to inherent the
objects you want to override this method
get data is inside the data access and
I'll override it using Google mocks
macros that was an essentially enable me
to change the behavior of that method in
the test in the test I can tell it what
to do but I do have to write the code to
do that this is the bare minimum I need
to write essentially it's a constant
method with no parameters called get
data and it returned a pair of twins and
I know the someone in the code that said
not to use pairs but that is a demo
that's so it's fine and similarly I have
a fake REST API client that we named
sorry and it inherited a REST API client
I'll do some trickery with the
constructor not to call it and so it
won't connect to a server or anything
and here I have a method with bad
little cottage to beget returns the
string and gain get a string on the way
and the test which I'm going to use for
all my different examples is my data
base returns dispel and I do that with
Google mock by using expect call and I
expected
I expect that when I Hall get data it
will repeatedly always return this data
I can tell it to for an exception of an
Kazu code up to me the quite a lot of
options there but this is what I need
here and I also expect macfay client to
call HTP get with this specifics drink
and that's it at least once because in
google mock verifying and setting the
behavior is done in the same place which
I don't like I think they should be
divided and but here I tell it not only
you should return the number three as a
string but unless that call was made at
least once the test should fail okay
this is what I'm doing here if you you
never see in a mocking form of before
it's a bit complex technical while to
wrap your head around this but
essentially that's all he can do what
the mocking framework and then I'll
create a new calculator and calculate
the next data and I found that running
it in debug will probably help explain
what happens there so if al Ron I'll get
to the actual code I'm testing you see
there's no assert ill because I have no
state to actually check because I faked
out the database and the server so what
I need to check is that the server was
called if your test is that if the user
is valid send an email you want to check
that the email was sent but there's no
email or just faked it out so I want to
check that the method call sent in the
email client was called so no certs so
the test looked a bit strange and if I
go in this is the code I'm testing very
trivial I will never test this code in
real production systems but hiland get
that access I'll get data back and the
data is essentially exactly what I told
him to want into that's what I said but
that's what
happens and here I'll build the some
sort of string and run HTTP GET with
that string and now the test basically
is over I don't really care what happens
after that because this is a fake object
I told him what to do just for the test
to pass and not fail but the actual
result of the test is here inside the
test which is very powerful because I
get to test things that are deep inside
my code I don't need some value I'll
just test something was cold and
obviously I needed to initialize the
class with those fake objects beforehand
I did construct an injection to do that
but that is part of using mocks and this
is how you do a tool Google mock now
with trample a it's very similar the
actual test will look about the same
with different values Hill is connecting
I told you that Google mock and Google
tests are tightly coupled and they're
not at the couple well integrated is the
word I'm looking for so you don't need
to do that but any other mocking thermic
you need to tell the unit testing
framework we have a problem and that's
what I'm doing here I copied that from
the site don't worry you don't need to
remember that and this is essentially
the same test
you see allow Co blah blah blah blah
return and the quail call for
expectation so we have two different ApS
but it is about the same and if you look
it's fake it in fake it the nice thing
is that I don't have any fake classes it
will do that for me as long as all the
method calls up your virtual and in fact
it all I need to say is mock with that
access and I'll get a magic class
already mocked so I don't need to write
classes and if they change I don't need
to change all my tests and when he
method HTTP GET is called return free I
find it to be more streamlined to read
it this way but I am coming from other
languages and that's how we do it in
dotnet and Java and I used to work for
mocking company for a company that made
mocking frameworks and that's the API we
liked and the verify checking that the
method was called
is done in the end just like an assert
which I like as well it's more clear
understandable what I'm testing you
because it comes at the end I'm checking
that HD Paquette was called at least
once and if we go to isolate applause
this is a completely different beast
first of all you don't need to create
any classes because it doesn't use any
classes it actually uses your real class
it just changes the way it walks didn't
run time so I have here an address and a
fake it but not only did I fake it for
whatever I have in this test I faked all
the future instances anywhere you write
new with that class
this is immensely powerful it only
depends the injection because I told him
that fake address God City will return
London if I'll takes a card res and try
to run it fake address get city and run
it then as you can tell
I'll get an empty string right but once
I pass this line like so and do the same
thing again then magically and this is a
real class I haven't created a fake
object it will return London you see I'm
using an actual address not just a point
of the class now what is really cool is
when I call get a dress form City
Factory whatever then it will use a
singleton returning that responded
singleton there's an actual new inside
we can run all the way there it will new
a singleton and if we go like so past
the singleton that singleton essentially
is fact as well because I told him
whatever used an address and its name is
singleton now singleton get city and
this is a class I just need it will
attend London as well and this is a
machine and it might Wharf your money
okay I have no opinion at least on the
topic basically depending on your
project and this is powerful
capabilities that you can harness
especially if your code is legacy code
with the law without any dependency
injection lot of things stuck together
huge monolith might save you some time a
lot of time it much might be worth it
and again not affiliated with them so
that's it now in C++ we have something
going for us um does the multiple assert
dilemma I've heard about the the single
assault whole every test should have
only single assert it is not a rule
never written anywhere but it is true
because the most things are testing the
test the test will be more complex but
sometimes my assert is actually a
singular self eaten several times for
example consider this example I am
taking a string and I pass that string
and I get a result back a single result
but it has a lot of aspects it's a movie
it's I as an IMDB ID a title a plot and
minimum length okay I want to test all
of those I don't need for tests to test
that now in other languages like C sharp
and Java L I might have a problem
because assertions there will for an
exception that I would they walk luckily
for me at least all of the unit s in
from okay so in simplest ass doesn't do
that which means that right now the test
is a problem because if I run the test
distant from the command line you see it
failed and he failed because the movie
name was not right it was wrong it
wasn't what I expected but I have no
clue about the rest of their assertions
whether or not they failed or passed and
I like to get as much information as I
can get and for that I can use something
else and all of those I just show you
have the same capability and that
instead of cell to use some other world
here they called expect expect says if
the assertion fails continue till the
end and just in the end tell me about it
and the reason we can do that is because
those don't force an exception just like
C sharp or Java
J unit that was written 1997 and no one
has ever thought about changing that
ever seen
but in surpluses we have so if I run the
same test now that I change it to expect
insert the set and I need to compile C++
for you then you see I'll get a better
or message the movie name is not correct
and the plot is not correct as well and
this is better because there's a
difference between one property is not
correct to all of the properties are not
correct and I don't want to write for
tests because essentially I'm testing
just one scene another cool thing about
unit testing for mocking C++ eye is that
it's movable in my belief because
failures don't fall exception just like
I show you you get better failure
message usually in C++ in any other
language in my experience I don't know
why and you have single powerful Excel
assert when going to catch and all its
derivative which also I find very useful
but there's another thing I like about
catch in that section anyone here is
familiar with test fixtures setup and
teardown if we look at the same example
from yesterday in any unit testing
framework J unit and unit all of those I
have the ability to define special
methods that will run before every test
and after every test I do to enable code
reuse or initialize my system and do
things that so I don't need to do them
in my tests so if I write it here and
heal the setup and the tail down then I
don't need to write it in my tests and
the tests look better unfortunately I
think it's a bad solution and by the way
a lot of consultant will think the exact
opposite
but i I've seen people mess this up
because first of all a new developer who
come you want a different behavior I'll
write it here and mess up your tests
second of all when this test here will
fail you start doing this go up go down
go up go down try to combine the test in
your head and in catch they did
something completely different although
it does support the feature if you want
to catch they have something called
sections and sections essentially is
writing a mini test inside your test you
see as
the initialization he'll and I have this
section that will run and have another
section he'll and they will run
individually in different execution
times if one fail and the other passes
that's fine I'll get those results it's
not like writing everything in the same
test and I haven't found a good way to
do that in manage languages because C++
is more powerful and not in a good way
anyway and those section enable me to
write better code and when developers
start with section inside the fixtures
they usually write better tests as well
in my experience so this is why I like
unit testing framework in C++ and I
think that you actually can do a better
job with those so how do you choose
there's so much things so many things to
choose form first of all decide whether
or not you need multi-platform support
some of those don't support your
platform of choice most of them will but
for example Microsoft in testing thermic
only works in Windows so you have to
think about that second of which is it
maintained go into the Gaeta page see
when was the last commit check whether
or not it has documentation
documentation usually a good way to
check whether or not the project is
maintained or not if it has like an
extensive documentation says someone
really cares about it ease of use how is
it for me to write tests how is it to
use the unit testing framework
deployment twice and execution-wise
how can you survive just this test what
happens when the tests fail
Co test fail and see if the error
message makes any sense for you and the
integration point in your environment
development and your build system are
very important and also between your
mocking the framework and your unit
testing framework as well and finally
your personal taste because we are
different I like H but doesn't that
doesn't matter because you might like
something completely different you might
like metal for example because it makes
everybody look at you differently
because I haven't showered in time
because I didn't have a lot of time but
just a quick glance you'll understand
what I'm talking about
Google the metal this is test with metal
okay
okay some people actually like the
syntax some don't and that's fine if you
like lambdas you might like it better
it's up to you and you might like
extremely plus plus because you come in
from that metal Java and it looks
exactly the same again your choice just
make sure it's maintained and finally
for those of you not writing any unit s
you have two options in the middle of
the night trying to tackle a bug in the
West yet you have to option being
frustrated cause the language be really
annoyed with whoever wrote the code or
start writing unit tests and it's
essentially your choice yeah always like
to leave people with some current some
quote I miss poor miss right vote from a
movie so thank you very much the
examples are there under my user in
github and you feel free to college me
in Twitter on my blog and if you have
any question I'll be here at least until
the afternoon you can come in ask me be
happy to answer thank you for listening
it's been a while
[Applause]